I was warned if you want to get thrown
out of Quentin until he knows home you
try to talk about violence
your ability to make a movie that by any
objective standards is among the most
violent movies made but have an audience
laugh during the time or come out of the
movie smiling how do you do that you can
see all kinds of movies but when a movie
really really does it to me it's because
it's made me feel many different
emotions during the course of it and
especially if I can pull off
contradictory emotions that can actually
work out and I do believe that I'm the
kind of director that I want to play you
as an audience I I want to be the
conductor and you're my Orchestra and
the sounds that I make you to make and
the feelings I get you to feel and then
I stop you from feeling those feelings
and I give you something else to feel
well if a director can do that if he can
directly can pull it off well that's a
real lucky audience member because
you've really had an experience that
night you went to the movies that was
worth leaving the house